BREAKNECK PACE THAT IT WAS TIME
TO GO.
>> Bret: JOHN ROBERTS,
CATHERINE HERRIDGE.
THANK YOU.
LET'S BRING IN THE PANEL.
MATT SCHLAPP, CONTRIBUTOR WITH
"THE HILL."
TOM BEVAN.
REAL CLEAR POLITICS.
AMY, TO YOU.
HOPE HICKS.
HARD TO OVERSTATE HER IMPORTANCE
FOR THIS PRESIDENT.
SHE HAS BEEN THERE.
PART COMMUNICATIONS DIRECTOR OR
PART BODY WOMAN.
>> SHE HAS LITERALLY BEEN BY HIS
SIDE FROM THE VERY BEGINNING.
AND A PERSON HE TRUSTED.
PROBABLY MORE THAN ANYBODY OTHER
THAN THE IMMEDIATE FAMILY.
THIS IS SOMEONE IN THE INNERMOST
CIRCLE.
I THINK JOHN'S POINT THAT HE
MADE ABOUT THE ISSUE OF SAYING
THERE ARE TIMES WHEN I HAVE SAID
WHITE LIES.
I'VE NEVER SAID ANYTHING THAT
WAS OLD     OUTWARDLY FALLS OR L
WAS OLD     OUTWARDLY FALLS OR E
ABOUT THE RUSSIAN INVESTIGATION.
BUT YOUR JOB AS THE WHITE HOUSE
COMMUNICATIONS DIRECTOR, THAT'S
A PRETTY DAMAGING PIECE OF
INFORMATION TO GET OUT THERE.
ANYTHING THAT'S PUT OUT ON THE
RECORD BY YOUR WHITE HOUSE
COMMUNICATIONS DIRECTOR HAS TO
COME THROUGH THAT FILTER OF
SOMEONE WHO HAS ADMITTED TO
SAYING THINGS THAT AREN'T TRUE
AT DIFFERENT TIMES.
I THINK THAT IS A PIECE OF IT.
I ALSO DON'T DOUBT --
>> Bret: WHITE HOUSE
COMMUNICATIONS DIRECTOR AND
PRESS SECRETARIES IN THE PAST
HAVE SAID THINGS THAT ARE
CLEARLY NOT ACCURATE BUT THEY
HAVEN'T BEEN QUOTED.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" HASN'T HAD
A HEADLINE THAT SAYS HOPE HICKS
KNOWLEDGES SHE SOMETIMES TELLS
WHITE LIES.
>> I DON'T DOUBT SHE IS READY TO
GO.
NOBODY CAN LIVE AT THIS LEVEL.
I THINK MOST FOLKS CAN MAKE IT A
YEAR TO AT THIS PACE.
USUALLY YOU SEE SOMEBODY LIVING
AT THE MIDTERM.
IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE THEY CAN
MAKE IT MUCH LONGER.
>> Bret: CHIEF OF STAFF JOHN
KELLY PUT OUT A STATEMENT.
"WHEN I BECAME I BECAME CHIEF OF
STAFF I REALIZED WHAT SO MANY
PEOPLE HAVE LEARNED ABOUT HOPE.
SHE IS STRATEGIC, POISE, WISE.
SHE DID A TREMENDOUS JOB.
SHE HAS SERVED OUR COUNTRY WITH
GREAT DISTINCTION.
TO SAY SHE WILL BE MISSED IS AN
UNDERSTATEMENT."
>> I THINK IT IS A BIG DEAL.
IT'S A BIG PIECE OF NEWS.
PRESIDENTS PUT PEOPLE AROUND
THEM THEY ARE COME TO BOW WITH
AND WHO THEY TRUST, WHO THEY
HAVE A RELATIONSHIP WITH.
SOMEONE WHO HAS THIS TYPE OF
RELATIONSHIP LEAVES, IT'S HARD
FOR PRESIDENT.
ONCE A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT
ABOUT THIS PRESIDENT IS I DON'T
THINK IT'S GOING TO CHANGE THAT
MUCH.
PEOPLE GO FROM INSIDE THE CIRCLE
TO OUTSIDE THE WHITE HOUSE, HE
COMMUNICATES WITH THEM.
I DON'T THINK HER RELATIONSHIP
WILL CHANGE THAT MUCH BUT THE
PHYSICAL PROXIMITY EVERY MORNING
STARTING OFF PLANNING THE DAY,
RESPONDING.
IT'S HARD.
IT'S HARD FOR PRESIDENTS WHEN
THIS HAPPENS.
>> Bret: THERE IS ANOTHER
PERSON NAMED SCHLAPP, WE SHOULD
POINT THAT OUT.
MERCEDES.
IT'S A BIG JOB, ESPECIALLY FOR A
WHITE HOUSE UNDER ATTACK.
>> IT'S A BIG JOB.
TRUMP IS THE COMMUNICATIONS
DIRECTOR OF HIS ADMINISTRATION
VIA HIS TWITTER ACCOUNT.
REGARDLESS OF WHAT THE
WHITE HOUSE SAYS, THE TIMING OF
THIS IS BOUND TO ENCOURAGE
SPECULATION OF THE GRIST FOR THE
PUNDIT AND RUMOR MILL ABOUT WHAT
DROVE HER TO MAKE THE
ANNOUNCEMENT.
SHE'S NOT LEAVING ANYTIME SOON.
SHE IS NOT BEING RUN OUT OF THE
BUILDING.
TRUMP HAS LOST ANOTHER PERSON.
THERE'S ONLY ONE, THE SOCIAL
MEDIA DIRECTOR, PART OF HIS
ORIGINAL TEAM.
HE LOST KEITH SCHILLER, HE LOST
A LOT OF FOLKS HE REALLY DOES
TRUST TO BE IN THAT BUILDING
WITH HIM.
WE WILL SEE HOW IT PLAYS OUT.
THERE ARE VERY FEW LEFT OUTSIDE
HIS FAMILY INSIDE THE BUILDING
WITH WHOM HE HAS THOSE BONDS.
>> Bret: I WANT TO PLAY,
MOMENTS AGO SENATOR RICHARD BURR
WAS ASKED ABOUT HOPE HICKS
RESIGNING.
HE IS THE CHAIR OF THE SENATE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE.
>> SHE REALLY DIDN'T PROVIDE FOR
US ANY INFORMATION ON THE
INVESTIGATION.
IT MAY BE THAT THE HOUSE IS
INVESTIGATING SOMETHING
DIFFERENT.
WE ARE LOOKING AT RUSSIAN
COLLUSION.
>> Bret: BASICALLY, AMY, BOTH
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS SAID
SHE TOOK PRIVILEGE ON A LOT OF
THE QUESTIONS THAT HAVE TO DO
WITH HER TIME IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
SHE ANSWERED QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
TRANSITION BUT NINE HOURS.
EVERY QUESTION, EVERY ANGLE,
EVERY KIND OF COMBINATION ON
CAPITOL HILL YESTERDAY.
>> THIS IS WHERE WE ARE.
DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO BE
FRUSTRATED.
REPUBLICANS ARE GOING TO SAY SHE
DID THE BEST OF HER ABILITY.
THERE WAS NO POSSIBILITY,
SENATOR BURR SAYS WE DON'T HAVE
ANY OPPORTUNITY TO SAY THIS IS
ABOUT COLLUSION.
THAT WAS CERTAINLY A BIG ISSUE
YESTERDAY.
I THINK THE BIGGER QUESTION AS
WE MOVE INTO THE MIDTERM
ELECTIONS AND THINK ABOUT WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN AFTERWARDS, WHO
WAS GOING TO BE AROUND THE
PRESIDENT IN THE SECOND HALF OF
HIS FIRST TERM.
THERE IS NORMALLY A LOT OF
TURNOVER AT THAT TIME.
THE PRESIDENTS PREPARE FOR THAT.
THEY KNOW WHO THE NEXT TEAM IS
GOING TO BE.
NOW I DON'T THINK WE HAVE A LOT
OF ANSWERS ON WHO IS IN THE
PIPELINE NOT JUST FOR THIS JOB.
I THINK WE ARE GOING TO SEE A
LOT OF TURNOVER IN BIGGER JOBS.
>> Bret: WHO IS THE TRUMP
WHISPER INSIDE THE WHITE HOUSE
NOW?
HOPE HICKS CLEARLY WISE.
>> I DON'T KNOW IF THAT CHANGES.
THEY HAVE A VERY TIGHT
RELATIONSHIP.
SHE IS PROBABLY THE NUMBER ONE
STAFFER IN MANY WAYS.
WORKS FOR IVANKA BEFORE THAT.
I DON'T SEE THAT RELATIONSHIP
CHANGING.
I THINK HE IS GOING TO REACH OUT
TO HER AND TALK TO HER ON A
REGULAR BASIS.
WHEN YOU GET DONALD TRUMP, HIS
NUMBER ONE RELATIONSHIP IS WITH
HIS FAMILY.
HE IS GOING TO CONTINUE TO TALK
TO THEM.
THEN HE ASKED THESE PEOPLE HE'S
KNOWN FOR A VERY LONG PERIOD
TIME THROUGHOUT HIS BUSINESS
CAREER.
HE IS CONSTANTLY REACHING OUT TO
PEOPLE AND GETTING FEEDBACK.
HE IS TALKING TO PEOPLE ON A
REGULAR BASIS.
>> Bret: IT COMES AS THERE IS
THIS SECURITY CLEARANCE
QUESTION.
JARED KUSHNER, THE SON-IN-LAW.
SENIOR ADVISOR.
WE TALKED ABOUT YESTERDAY.
THERE ARE MANY OTHERS, A FEW
DOZEN, WE ARE TOLD WHO HAD
SECURITY QUESTIONS AND MAYBE
EVEN A DOWNGRADE.
AS FAR AS CLEARANCE.
THAT IS ALSO HAPPENING AT THE
SAME TIME.
THERE IS A LOT OF THINGS
HAPPENING AT THIS WHITE HOUSE.
>> YEAH.
JOHN KELLY IS TRYING TO DEAL
WITH THE ISSUE OF SECURITY
CLEARANCES WRIT LARGE INSIDE THE
WHITE HOUSE BUT THE JARED
KUSHNER SECURITY CLEARANCE ISSUE
IS ONE THAT HAS GARNERED THE
MOST ATTENTION BECAUSE OF THE
PORTFOLIO HE HAS COME OF THE
PROXIMITY.
WHETHER HE CAN DO HIS JOB
WITHOUT HAVING THE TOP-SECRET
SECURITY CLEARANCE.
I THINK THAT REMAINS AN OPEN
QUESTION.
A LOT OF THE SPECULATION ABOUT I
THINK HIS SECURITY CLEARANCE, WE
SAW THIS "WASHINGTON POST"
ARTICLE WHICH I THOUGHT WAS
UNNECESSARILY OMINOUS ABOUT HIM
BEING MANIPULATED BY -- HE IS
THE SON-IN-LAW OF THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES.
CERTAINLY THE PRESIDENT CAN
GRANT HIM NEED TO KNOW AUTHORITY